In order to have any positive meaning in
your life,
you have to identify the goal and you
have to be working towards it and there
is a technical reason for that and the
technical reason as far as I can tell is
that the circuitry that produces the
kind of positive emotion that people
really like is only activated when you
noticed that your.
Because when you're proceeding towards a
goal that you value and so that means
that if you don't have a goal that you
value,
you can't have any positive emotions.
So technically that's the incentive
reward system and it's the underlying
circuitry as dopaminergic and when that
circuitry is activated,
then it's part of the exploratory
circuit.
It makes you.
It gives you the sense of being actively
engaged in something worthwhile and
that's you know you.
You tend to think of positive emotion is
something produced by reward,
but there's two kinds of positive
emotion.
One is the reward that's associated with
satiation and that's conservatory reward
and that's the reward you get when
you're hungry and you eat.
But the thing about eating when you're
hungry is that destroys the framework
within which you are operating,
right?
It's time to eat what you eat and then
that frameworks no longer relevant.
So the conservatory reward eliminates
the value of framework and then you're
stuck with,
well,
what are you going to do next?
And so the conservatory reward has with
it its own problems.
But the incentive reward is constantly
what keeps you moving forward and
incentive reward because it's
dopaminergic also is analgesic,
literally analgesics.
So if you're in pain,
you take opiates and that that will cut
the pain,
but so will psychomotor stimulants like
cocaine or amphetamines.
And so it's literally the case that if
you're engaged in something that's
engaging and you're working towards a
goal that you're going to feel less
pain.
And you can see this happening with
athletes who you know,
they'll break their thumb or something
or maybe sometimes even their ankle and
they'll keep playing the game.
Of course afterwards they're suffering
like mad.
But the fact that they're so filled with
goal-directed enthusiasm means that
whether Peyton systems are in some sense
shut off.
So that's an interesting thing because
what it suggests,
I mean then you could imagine,
I might say,
well how happy you are you that you've
made a certain amount of progress and if
you think about it,
what you'd say is,
well,
it depends on how much progress and in
relationship to what so hypothetically
you're going to be happier if you've
made quite a bit of progress towards a
really important goal and then you have
to think through what it means for a
goal to be really important because
that's not obvious.
Now you could say,
here in this class and you're listening
to some information and maybe there's
two reasons for that.
You might find the information
interesting per se,
but let's forget about that for a
minute.
You need to listen to the information so
that you can do well on the assignment
so that you can do well in the class.
You need to do well in your classes so
that you can finish up your degree.
You need to finish up your degree so
that you can find your place in the
world.
You need to do that so that you're
financially stable and maybe you can
start a family and have a life and
that's part of being a good person,
something like that,
and so that's a hierarchy of goals and
you might say that being a good person
would be the thing,
however vaguely thought through.
That's at the top of that hierarchy,
and then when you're doing things that
serve the ultimate purpose,
then you're going to find those more
meaningful and that meaning is actually
produced as a consequence of the
engagement of this exploratory circuit
that's nested right down in your
hypothalamus.
It's really,
really old.
It's as old as thirst and it's as old as
hunger.
It's really an old system and so you
want to have that thing activated.